I'm married. I'm married. You're
obsessed with
obsessed. She's the last woman I will
commit suicide and marry her.
[Music]
She's a curse.
Anyway, what we say, you know what I say
to you? When you go to the teach of
Islam is lo and I advise you to do more
studies. Do you mind spending 5 minutes
talking about salvation in Islam? I'm
not I did already. I'm I'm not going to
interfere. I just want to don't
entertain her because she's
also
brother. She's a dirty mel curse her and
b her tongue.
two to five.
Yeah. So two to five minutes just just
telling us about
so salvation in Islam. We have to
understand it as Christians. Then if you
allow me
to also I mean I mean you share the same
message and that's it. Really? We can
tell. Go ahead. No, you go first. I did
already but you keep asking the same
question. Yeah. Yeah. I want it
condensed now. Yeah. Go concrete. Go.
was a condensed
milk sweeten up condensed
milk. Go ahead. Go ahead. Tell us where
is the conclusion to the nation
situation. Yeah. Okay. Uh I've listened
to to Shamzi. I think we've had a good
discussion. Yes, indeed. Yeah. About
Jesus Christ. I think it's it's clear
that see thinks we are s when we follow
Christ when we depend on the work of the
cross he
thinks to do that and that's not enough
for salvation cuz I have many behind
me that's not the right way to attain
salvation so I would like to share my
position as a Christian that I follow
Christ because I believe that is God's
part of the
Godhead.
Jesus
mean sorry I mean I don't have say sorry
she's Christian she's doing that so I I
believe that Jesus is God I believe that
God the Father God the Son God the Holy
Spirit are worthy of worship and I
believe this
one. That's what I believe. So when you
say God, like shampoo, three in one. I I
I can I can think the Holy Spirit, I can
think Jesus Christ. When I hear Jesus, I
can think God. No problem at all. I
don't have any issue with that. I
believe that Jesus Christ came down to
earth as part of God the father. Part
of Jesus being part of the godhead. He
was sent down to represent God the
father and God the holy spirit. And the
mission was to come down from heaven
take human form and died for the sins of
humanity. So that that's why you you
took upon the curse of the world and he
was crucified on the cross the same way
that people were crucified like people
that had committed major sins like the
thieves and everything. So Jesus took
the same path to take the curse from the
world so that if we believe in him the
Bible tells us that if we believe it in
him we can attain eternal life. That's
the way that we that's the way that we
see it. So
therefore, because we believe that we
cannot attain salvation without Christ,
we have to depend upon the work that he
did on the cross, dying and shedding
blood. That's the only that's the
ultimate sacrifice and that's the only
way we can attain salvation. That's our
belief. No, no, it's conclusion. I have
to conclude. This is that's my belief.
Like when you say
after let finish and I will conclude.
Don't worry. So that's my that's my
belief as a Christian that's it. Anyway,
it was a same thing. I would say we had
very very nice uh discussion and
respectful discussion and to be honest
Michael sometimes. Yeah, let me finish
it. Sometimes you know when I come to
speak and I have some disc I have
discussion with some people that I'm not
they're stubborn insult they just shout.
He put me off you know like I don't want
to come back to speakers but speaking
with you and speaking with I just spoke
with another person before you I had
very respectful and nice discussion and
that motivates me to come more corner I
disagree
which is a
good again trust me you will see me next
time I'll be shouting alhamdulillah
don't come back next time then I'll
speak to someone else thank you for
letting me know I'm speak to you next
time anyway what I was going to say to
conclude alhamdulillah
We look at Islam that's one of the the
greatest miracle and the beauty of Islam
which distinguish Islam from any way of
life and any religion. Islam goes in
line with our sound universal intellect
and our natural inclination. The one
that gave us sound intellects and these
tools which call universal tools to
utilize them to know the truth and the
force is the creator. Some of us due to
our environment will be affected and we
should and we start instead of using
them we start using our culture over
them. So Islam there's only one God.
Even how Allah describe himself simple
logical perfect rational way.
Allah Allah is one unique master
self-sufficient everything is in need of
him. He's he's not in need of no one. He
he begget not neither was he begotten.
And there's nothing like onto Allah. We
believe based upon Allah's justice and
Allah's mercy and Allah's wisdom. He
chose people amongst us like Moses,
Jesus, Abraham, Jeremiah, Ishmael,
Jacob, Isaac,
Muhammadam to teach us how to worship
God and to teach us about our purpose in
this life in detail. None of the
prophets claim to be God or a son of
God. Likewise, we believe there's only
the only way for there's way for
salvation. Firstly, by the grace of God
because we believe regardless how much
you worship God, you will never be able
to repay back Allah for his blessings.
Allah's blessings is too much like even
our eyes and the air everything. So
however we believe also to gain Allah
blessing and Allah's mercy and par I
mean paradise and eternal life is by
believing in God the way he want to
believe in him and following the
teaching of his prophets. If I was alive
at the time of Jesus, I have to follow
Jesus teaching to be saved. Lord of
Paul, I have to at the time of Moses
likewise. And now the last prophet is
Muhammadatam. And you can go back to the
video. I've already explained why Islam
is the truth. Why Muhammad wasallam must
be prophet of God. However, the
salvation that they believe the
Christians does not go in line with
Jesus teaching. In the Bible, when the
young boy asked Jesus, "How can I attain
the salvation, eternal life, the kingdom
of God?" Jesus never said, "Believe, I'm
going to die for your sins." He said,
"Follow the Mosaic law, which is doing
good deeds." Likewise, if you read the
Old Testament, all the prophets of God
in the Old Testament came with the same
teaching. Generally speaking, like
Prophet Muhammad, believe in God, God's
mercy first and do righteous action. As
for believing Jesus died for your sins,
that is not the teaching of Jesus or
other prophets. Is a paganism teaching.
Okay, that was influenced by Paul.
That's why Paul had a problem with some
of the true followers of Jesus because
he was teaching something clearly goes
and gets teaching the teaching of Jesus.
To conclude more, Islam is the way of
life. The fastest growing religion on
the face of the earth is Islam. The
western world brought Christianity to
our continent Africa above us. The same
people force Christianity on us that are
leaving Christianity and why is
spreading Islam even though there is big
and huge propaganda against Islam. If
the propaganda that is being waged
against Islam, if it was against any
religion, that religion will be died. It
would die long time ago. But Islam never
died fighting back because Islam many
British women, British men, European
men, women see that the real meaning of
freedom to be a Muslim and to follow
God's teaching. And when you accept
Islam, you're not losing Jesus. You're
going to believe in Jesus the way Jesus
wants to believe in him, not Paul or
Mark. Thank you for listening. Nice
talking to you. May Allah guide you in
truth. Amen. Next victim. Ask next
victim. I'm in such